[MUSIC PLAYING]
MANUSHI SHAH: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to the Talks
at Google event.
I am Manushi Shah.
And I would like
to introduce Isaac.
So we are here for his
book "Eyes Wide Open."
Isaac was born with a rare
degenerative disease of retina
that caused him to
gradually lose his sight.
Despite all the hurdles that his
disease has brought upon him,
Isaac has led a very
successful life.
He played Weasel on
"Saved by the Bell."
He graduated from Harvard
College at age of 19
with a degree in mathematics
and computer science.
He also graduated from
Harvard Law School
and served as a law clerk for
Supreme Court Justice Sandra
O'Connor and Ruth Ginsburg.
He also transformed a struggling
concrete subcontractor
into an industry leading
with $150 million business.
And along with this, he has
also founded Hope for Vision
which is a nonprofit that funds
the development of treatments
for binding diseases.
In "Eyes Wide Open," which is
part autobiography and part
self-help, Isaac Lidsky
shares a very inspiring story
of achieving
success in his life.
So I would like to
introduce Isaac.
ISAAC LIDSKY: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
Excellent.
How's everybody doing?
AUDIENCE: Good.
ISAAC LIDSKY: All right.
Yeah.
I was going to say,
I got to hear you,
because I obviously
can't see you.
I say that sighted people
are terrified of speaking
to big crowds,
but us blind folks
are terrified of
speaking to empty rooms.
[LAUGHTER]
So I want to know
you're out there.
All right.
So I'm going to ask
you to take a car
ride with me this afternoon.
Imagine yourself taking a car
So let me give you the context.
You are 13 years old.
So I know for some
of you Googlers,
that's not that far back, but
for others it's a while back.
So take a second, think
back to who you were at 13,
what was going on your
life at that time.
All right, so you're 13.
And your sibling has always
been a little clumsy.
It's sort of part of her sunny,
absent minded disposition.
It's kind of cute.
But not recently.
Recently, there have been some
pretty nasty bumps and bruises
and some serious scares.
Tragedy was narrowly
avoided a couple times.
It seems the problem
has something to do
with your sibling's eyesight.
Your mom takes you all to the
neighborhood ophthalmologist
office for a checkup.
Now there's nothing
wrong with your eyes.
Right?
Remember you're 13 years
old, so you're perfect,
at least you think you are.
And everything's going well.
Nothing wrong with your eyes,
but still the ophthalmologist
is clearly troubled
by something he sees.
And he tells your mom
to take all of you kids
to the Medical
Research Institute
at the medical school at
the university in town.
So off you go.
And after a very
long day of strange
and sort of grueling
eye exams, the expert
tells you that,
like your sibling,
you have a eye disease that
causes progressive loss
of sight and blindness.
So that's what happened to me.
The sibling was my sister Daria.
The research institute was the
Bascom Palmer Eye Institute
at the University of Miami.
It was 1993.
And I was 13 years old.
Now before that day, I was
living a Hollywood fairy tale.
I was born to a middle
class family in America
to parents who loved
me and nurtured me
and cared for my education.
I loved school.
It came easy to me.
And I enjoyed it very much.
And as you heard, the Hollywood
part, I mean it literally.
I grew up acting.
I did about 100 to
150 commercials,
got some lucky breaks
here and there,
and was ultimately
cast as Weasel Wyzell
on NBC TV'S "Saved by
the Bell: The New Class."
I was the sort of dorky
character, the nerd,
so it was quite a challenge
for me as an actor.
Nonetheless, I played that role.
So that was before.
At the end of the long day at
Bascom Palmer Eye Institute,
everything changed.
Right?
Dr. W. called us
into his office.
He took a medical textbook
off the shelf behind his desk.
He flipped through the pages,
found the one he wanted,
put the book on
the desk facing us.
And he pointed to
some photographs.
He said those are pictures
of the retinas of patients
with a disease called
retinitis pigmentosa, or RP.
RP causes progressive loss of
sight and ultimately blindness.
Daria and Isaac have
RP and will go blind.
There are no treatments.
There are no cures.
We don't really know
much about the disease.
Good luck.
That was it.
We got up and we left.
And we got back my mom's
car for a long ride home.
So that's the car
ride I want you
to imagine yourselves taking
with me this afternoon, please.
So you sit in the
back of the car.
Your mom tries very hard not
to cry, with little success.
Your siblings are crying, too.
And you are trying
to make some sense
of the diagnosis of the
information you've just
gained for miles and miles.
So how do you feel?
And what is it that you're
thinking in that car?
Fear is a powerfully
destructive force in our lives.
Fear distorts our reality.
Under the warped logic
of fear, anything
is better than the uncertain.
Fear will fill the
void at all costs,
passing off what you
dread for what you know,
offering up the worst in
place of the ambiguous,
substituting
assumption for reason.
Psychologists call
it awfulizing.
Fear replaces the
unknown with the awful.
Now fear is self-realizing.
When we face the greatest
need to look beyond ourselves,
to gain more information,
to think critically,
fear beats a retreat
deep inside your mind
shrinking and
distorting your view,
drowning your capacity
for critical thought
with a flood of
disruptive emotions.
When you face a
compelling opportunity
to transcend, to
thrive, to overcome,
fear lulls you into
inaction enticing
you to passively watch its
prophecies fulfill themselves.
So how did I feel in the
back of my mom's car?
I felt terrified.
And what was I thinking?
I was thinking blindness
will absolutely ruin my life.
In fact, I wasn't thinking
that so much as I knew it.
I didn't think it, I knew it.
Here's what I knew in the
back of that car that day.
Blindness will ruin my life.
Blindness is a death
sentence for my independence.
Blindness is the end
of achievement for me.
It means that I am going
to live an unremarkable
life, small and sad.
I'm going to live
that life alone.
No woman is going to
love or respect me.
I'm not going to love
or respect myself.
So I won't have any kids, which
is probably for the better,
because no child deserves that.
And in a sense, I'm always
going to be a child.
So that's what I knew in the
back of that car that day.
Now fear's work doesn't end
with the baseless reality
it concocts in your mind.
That's where fear's
work really begins.
To perpetuate this reality,
fear must trick you
into playing your part.
Now fear's accomplices in this
con are heroes and villains.
Fear conjures up a world in
which heroes and villains
do battle for your fate like
gods of Greek mythology acting
from Mount Olympus.
Blame your villains, fear
will whisper in your ear.
The fault lies with others, the
problem is your circumstances.
Worship your heroes,
fear will admonish you.
They have the power to fix
this, they can save you.
Your heroes will make you happy.
The drama is epic and endless.
Heroes and villains doing
battle for your fate.
You sit back.
You try to take it all in.
You try to keep it all straight.
You try to figure out
where it's all going.
But it's all smoke and mirrors.
It's a diversion.
It's special effects.
What really matters
is that you have
become a cooperative
participant in fear's reality.
Right?
You play nice.
You don't question the premise.
You abdicate responsibility.
You blame and credit others.
Meanwhile, fear's
spell remains unbroken.
So my villain was Blindness,
not with a lowercase
b as in the condition
of sightlessness,
but Blindness with a capital
B, this amorphous bogeyman
that was going to hunt me
down and destroy my life.
My heroes were the brilliant
research scientists
working so hard to deliver
a cure for my disease.
They would do it in time.
They would save me.
They simply had to.
Living in the
reality of my fears,
my life became a race
against the clock.
I wasn't in the race.
I was on the sidelines, right?
Watching as Blindness
was out way in front
and only widening the gap.
Didn't look very good for me.
Now those were some really
dark years of my life.
Then I learned to see through
my fear, eyes wide open.
If you can believe it, it
began with my mother-in-law,
though she's an unlikely
heroine in the story,
though at the time
she was the mother
of my girlfriend, Dorothy.
So Brenda is an
occupational therapist.
She was the director
of occupational therapy
at the Lucerne
Spinal Injury Center.
Her typical patient was a woman
who was thrown by a horse,
instantly became a quadriplegic.
Brenda's patient meets
with doctors and nurses
has some surgeries, mourns
with friends and family.
Then she meets Brenda.
Brenda's job is the rest
of the patient's life.
So Brenda assesses the
patient's capabilities,
surveys the myriad tools
and technologies that
are available to supplement
those capabilities.
She develops discrete solutions
for concrete problems.
Maybe she rigs up a
homemade attachment
to make a joystick on a
wheelchair more accessible.
Or she introduces tools to
help her patient feed herself,
grooming and hygiene, getting in
and out of bed, reading a book.
Right?
Take the problems one at a
time, figure out a solution.
That's Brenda's perspective.
So when Dorothy
and I were dating,
without us knowing
anything about it,
Brenda began to
research some solutions
for the partially
sighted and the blind.
And one thing led to another.
And she found Chris.
Chris was an expert in the
field who worked in Boston where
Dorothy and I were living.
I went to go meet with Chris.
And it completely
changed my life.
So I walk into Chris's office.
And right away she asks me,
Isaac, do you ever use a cane?
I'm a little confused
and I'm really annoyed.
I'm thinking to myself,
no, I don't use a cane.
I mean I still see too well
to use a cane, don't I?
I mean isn't she's
supposed to be the expert?
Besides I'm not here
to talk about a cane.
A cane is like an
arbitrary detail, right?
We were talking about blindness.
I say her, no, Chris,
I don't use cane.
She says, well, do you bump
into things and hurt yourself?
I'm thinking of course
I bump into things
and hurt myself all the time.
In fact, two days ago, I walked
right into a fire hydrant,
splitting my pants
against my shin.
It bled a ton and it left
me with a heinous bruise.
So I rolled up the
leg of my jeans,
showed the bruise to Chris.
I said, Chris, yeah, you
could say I bump into things
and hurt myself.
No big deal.
I really want Chris to
understand how little I
care about bumping into things.
Right?
Now is not my problem.
Today is not my problem.
Bumping into things
is not my problem.
My problem is tomorrow,
the future, is blindness.
My life is going to end, right?
My problem is that
I am losing my sight
and there's nothing
I can do about it.
Chris says to me, you know
Isaac, if you used a cane,
you'd bump into things less
and you'd hurt yourself less.
Man, it was an
obvious point, right?
Pretty obvious point.
Now I know you guys
are all Googlers here,
so you're very smart.
I'm only a little
embarrassed to admit
it was such an obvious point
for me that day that it really
was like an epiphany.
And I realized that
there is only now.
There is only
today, this moment.
In that moment, I
saw that everything
I thought I knew about blindness
was a complete fiction borne
of my fears, lies.
What did I really know about
going blind or being blind?
Absolutely nothing.
What had I done
to learn about it?
Nothing.
So I was trapped
in fear's tunnel
unable to see the unbounded
potential, the vast landscape,
that lay just beyond.
Chris's point about the cane
was a pinprick of bright light
that led me out of that tunnel.
There was something that I
could do right away, right now,
today, to make my life a little
easier, to make my life better.
I caught on quickly.
I said what else can I do?
Chris had all sorts of ideas--
screen reading software to
interact with my computer using
my ears instead of
my eyes, a technique
called sighted
guide to walk around
with people more
naturally and more
safely, techniques and
systems to organize
my clothing and my shoes
so I could dress myself
and match, or at least
wear what I wanted to wear.
Simple solutions for discrete,
specific, practical problems.
So I decided that day
in Chris's office,
made myself a promise,
whenever I feel afraid,
I'm going to ask
myself two questions--
one, what precisely is
my problem, right now,
broken down into its
smallest, most discrete,
most manageable form?
Right now, what's my problem?
Two, what precisely
can I do about it?
No heroes, no villains, me.
Now a word of caution, you
have to answer those questions
for yourself in the
vein of like C-SPAN
coverage of some boring and
mundane procedural committee
hearing or something like that.
You can't answer that question
in the vein of a Hollywood
blockbuster.
OK?
There's no action sequences, no
special effects, no soundtrack.
It's just dialogue, no drama.
When I committed to answer
those two questions for myself
in that way whenever I faced
fear, my life turned around.
I took control of my reality.
I chose how I wanted to live
my life and who I wanted to be.
I broke fear's spell.
I went on to build a very
blessed life for myself
on that uncharted terrain
beyond fear's tunnel.
I did marry.
Dorothy and I had triplets.
And we enjoy that so much
that we had a fourth child,
sweet baby Clementine.
So 6 and 1/2 year old triplets
and a 15-month-old baby.
I am immensely blessed
and happy and fulfilled.
But if I had not seen through
the reality of my fears,
I would have lived that reality.
I'm absolutely
certain of that fact.
So I want to say
it one more time.
If I hadn't seen
through my fears,
I would have lived that really.
So.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MANUSHI SHAH: Thank you so much.
Thank you so much for
a great introduction.
I would also like to open
the floor for any Q&A
that people would have.
In the meantime, I have
a question for you.
ISAAC LIDSKY: Sure.
MANUSHI SHAH: Despite
all these hurdles,
it's very difficult to even
imagine being in that situation
that you were in, what
kept you motivated?
ISAAC LIDSKY: So the way
in which I lost my sight,
it was a progressive condition.
If you picture like a
jumbotron screen at an arena,
so imagine that the
LED bulbs on the screen
are randomly breaking
slowly over time.
And so you're watching my life
as a movie on this screen.
And at first, you might
not even notice it.
Then it becomes annoying.
Certain parts of the screen
are better than others.
It created all these
bizarre effects.
Objects would sort of appear
and morph and disappear.
If I got information
through other means,
through my fingers,
if someone told me
what I was looking at,
then suddenly I saw it.
So the experience, it was
challenging to put it mildly.
But it was also a real gift.
It turned out to be a
real gift, because I
got a peek behind the
curtain into sort of the way
the mind works.
And this illusion of sight
was shattered for me.
So sight is something we
experience as objective truth,
as reality, as something
that's out there,
when it's totally a creation
of our own mind, which
is built on much more than
just data from the eyes.
So anyway, having sort
of seeing first hand,
literally seeing, the
way we are empowered
to create an experience
for ourselves that
is so immersive and complete
that we then believe it to be
true and objective, that was
this sort of eye opening,
you know eyes wide open
vision, that like I said
turned out to be the
greatest blessing in my life.
Because we create our
realities in so many ways,
self-limiting assumptions,
our fears, our misconceptions
about success and failure,
strength and weakness,
the way we sort of misperceive
luck, oversimplify luck,
and on and on and on.
So what kept me going was
really at the end of the day,
this certainty that in every
moment, in every moment,
we choose who we
are and how we want
to live our lives independent
of the circumstances we face.
MANUSHI SHAH: Absolutely.
You mentioned
briefly about luck.
How much do you think luck
plays a role in our lives?
ISAAC LIDSKY: So
there is no question
that luck, happenstances,
circumstances
beyond our control play
a major factor in life.
I think, however, that we tend
to if not misperceive luck,
then certainly oversimplify it.
So what do I mean?
For example, the notion that
there's good luck and bad luck,
or that there are events
that have an independent sort
of value of good or bad.
I think the truth is a lot
more nuanced and complex,
and events are events.
And whether they're
good or bad, who knows?
And better than who knows, it's
kind of within our control.
So for example, I was
lucky to go blind.
It may sound like a
weird thing to say.
But in my experience, in
my life, the blessings,
the perspective, the life
that it has given me,
there's just no question, it
was one of the best things
that ever happened to me.
Another way we tend to
misperceive luck, I think, is,
again, we think that
there's a pretty clear,
bright line between
circumstances within
our control and circumstances
without our control,
you know circumstances
we cannot control.
And again, I think the
truth is really far more
nuanced and complex.
Really most things are
kind of in that gray area.
And we have a lot more control
over events in our lives,
and certainly the way we
experience those events,
how they manifest themselves
in our lives than we think.
MANUSHI SHAH: OK.
We have a question
from the audience.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
ISAAC LIDSKY: Hi.
AUDIENCE: That day when you were
13 when you got the diagnosis,
how long did it
take for your vision
to degenerate to the point
where you were legally blind?
And then how long until you
totally lost your sight?
ISAAC LIDSKY: Sure.
Thanks.
That's a great question.
I mean the short
answer is who knows?
It's hard to say.
This really is the sort
of progressive and sort
of slow death of
photoreceptor cells.
So when did it start?
Who knows.
When did it end?
Hard to say.
I know that when I was diagnosed
when I was 13, at the time,
I would have said I see as
well as any of my peers.
I'm not sure that's
actually true.
I literally don't know.
There's some little
stories or anecdotes.
Maybe I was already starting
to lose a meaningful amount
of cells, maybe not.
But so, 13, wouldn't have
said I had any problems.
In my mid to late
teens, it started
to become a real nuisance,
kind of transitioning
into a disability.
And then by my early to
mid 20s, I was essentially
living as a blind person.
By the time I was like 25,
I had really no useful sight
to speak of.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ISAAC LIDSKY: Sure.
MANUSHI SHAH: We have another
question from the audience.
ISAAC LIDSKY: Sure.
AUDIENCE: It's been almost
30 years since you've
been diagnosed.
In that time, has there been
any medical breakthroughs
in this condition?
Or is it still kind of
a blindness sentence?
ISAAC LIDSKY: Well, first
of all, it's been 24 years.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
ISAAC LIDSKY: Definitely older
than most of the people here,
but it's not been 30 years.
OK.
I'm sorry, what
was the question?
No.
So yeah.
There's been a lot of progress.
It's really actually
quite remarkable.
Without boring you
with all the details,
I am convinced I will regain
a substantial amount of sight.
Whether it's three
years from now,
or five years, or
10 years, who knows?
And how much sight and
how useful, who knows?
But I tell all those
researchers that I've
been lucky to get to
know over the years
that if I could see my
kids' faces, I'm set.
That's all I need.
And Dorothy has saved
a lot of great pictures
for me, so I look forward to
going through all of those
someday.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MANUSHI SHAH: I have
a question for you.
So is there anything
you wish you
had known earlier in your
life that would have helped
or at least eased
your struggles a bit?
ISAAC LIDSKY: Yeah, you
know it took some time
to get to Chris's office.
And there were some dark
years, as I mentioned.
And you know whether
we call it denial,
or whatever it was, it
would have been nicer
a little earlier
on to maybe start
focusing on the practical,
immediate solutions
to my day-by-day instead
of really insisting
that my challenge
began and ended
with the crusade for a cure.
MANUSHI SHAH: Makes sense.
Do you have a question?
OK.
AUDIENCE: I came to your
talk today because--
I have to confess,
I didn't know who
you were until two days
ago, and I read an op-ed
that you had written, I believe
it was in the "New York Times."
And you recounted an anecdote
in which you were making coffee
in the kitchen in the office.
Right?
And a woman came up to you
and she said, here, let me--
she was going to sort of--
ISAAC LIDSKY: She took over.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
She took over, right?
And you said, you know,
I can make coffee myself,
thank you very much.
And she says, sure,
I know you can.
But you always put the
grounds in the wrong bin.
ISAAC LIDSKY: The
paper recycling bin.
AUDIENCE: So that anecdote
sort of resonated with me
because you know there are--
we all kind of when we
interact with people,
perhaps there are a certain set
of assumptions that we hold.
And so I think in that
anecdote, you sort of
said, well, your
assumptions were, I guess,
you had this sort of
realization that an assumption
you had made about why she was
intervening was perhaps wrong.
What would you say--
like what other kinds
of insights has--
like what would
you say is like--
you know, if blindness
is a gift, what
other kinds of insights would
you say it has given you?
ISAAC LIDSKY: Well, so the
insight into our awesome power.
I mean awesome in the
sort of more literal way
than the conventional
use of the term.
But our power to shape our own
realities, the insights that I
gained into that
are invaluable to me
and has had such a powerful
positive effect in my life.
I'll say that I'm
certain, I'm convinced,
I'm passionate about the
fact that this vision,
this sort of insight into
the way our brains work,
it's for everybody.
It's not about blindness.
It's not about disability.
It's not even necessarily only
about challenges or obstacles
in life.
It's an opportunity to live with
awareness and accountability
and intention that has
been so liberating for me
and so empowering in my life.
That's why I wrote the book.
I wrote the book
really because I
wanted to share this
perspective with folks.
Frankly, I wanted to put
it down in words on paper
for my children to
read, maybe when
they get a little bit
older and more sensible,
because they don't make
any good decisions today.
[LAUGHTER]
So I guess I hesitate
to say blindness per se
is the source or the
sort of the locus
of the insight or
the perspective
if that makes sense.
Cool.
MANUSHI SHAH: Thank you so much.
What advice would
you give to people
who are either going
through this or just
in general for people?
Like there are lots of fears
that everyone fears, right?
ISAAC LIDSKY: Sure
MANUSHI SHAH: It could be
physical, it could be mental,
it could be anything.
If you were to tell them
small steps they could take
to get to the point where
you have been at this point,
what would it be?
ISAAC LIDSKY: Sure.
So if we're talking about fear
specifically, as I was saying,
focus on what's
precisely the problem,
break it down to small parts.
Focus on what you
can do about it.
Search your life for
heroes and villains,
because they're figments
in your mind that
can be very pernicious.
Generally, I think that we
would we would all do better
to pay attention to the profound
difference between what we know
and what we think we know.
We get ourselves into a lot
of trouble that with fear.
But the fear stuff and
overcoming fear is obviously
is a key theme in the
book, and it's obviously
what I chose to
talk about today,
but really more generally
it's this idea that whatever
circumstances we encounter,
what we do with it
and how we manifest them our
lives, what we make of them
is entirely within our control.
And for me, I need no more
proof of that than the fact
that always there
are people who have
done far more with far less and
been a lot happier doing it.
Right?
So if that's true, it just
can't be the circumstances
that's the problem.
MANUSHI SHAH: Right.
Makes sense.
Thank you so much
for your account.
It was wonderful
having you here well.
ISAAC LIDSKY: Thanks
for inviting me.
MANUSHI SHAH: Thank
you so much for coming.
I encourage everyone
to read his book.
It's very inspiring.
It's an autobiography,
yet it's very inspiring.
I think I found it very useful
and amazing to read through it.
ISAAC LIDSKY: Thank you.
MANUSHI SHAH: Thank
you so much for coming.
ISAAC LIDSKY: Thanks
for having me.
MANUSHI SHAH: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]